so it looks like Marvel Studios right
now has narrowed down the choices for
who they want the director to be for
Avengers Secret Wars and this is a big
deal this is a huge decision this is
supposed to be bigger than Avengers end
game not just by a little bit but by a
lot so they need an incredible director
behind the project and honestly two of
the choices that we've heard about so
far are Top Notch and I think would do
an insanely good job one comes in the
form of director Sean Levy who is
currently directing Deadpool 3 for
Marvel Studios and I've said this before
but don't sleep on Deadpool 3 because
this movie is going to be a lot bigger
than just Deadpool and Wolverine now of
course obviously it's going to focus on
them and if it was literally just the
two of them fighting each other the
entire movie a lot of us would probably
be okay with that but in terms of how
it's going to impact the overall MCU
story it's huge and it has a lot of
components to it that make Sean Levy
directing Deadpool 3 a great option for
directing Secret Wars as well and the
other director is related to Marvel as
well and he is super qualified but first
let's dive into Sean Levy so if you
don't know Sean Levy he's worked on some
amazing things he got stranger things
going and he was a producer for the show
he directed free guy which I know a lot
of people watched which had Ryan
Reynolds and he also directed the atom
project which had Ryan Reynolds as well
and Mark Ruffalo so he's worked with
Marvel actors before and Ryan Reynolds
has stated that he loves working with
Sean and quite honestly Marvel Studios
themselves have put a lot of trust into
Sean Levy by having him direct Deadpool
3. this movie is going to be absolutely
iconic Ryan Reynolds best character Hugh
Jackman's best character and returning
as that character after many many years
of not playing that character and he
himself even recently has stated how
huge this is R-rated very much so but
you have two major movie stars together
in a movie playing their most iconic
signature your roles that is director
heaven and so the story the tone the
movie itself leans into that gift of
having Deadpool and Wolverine
co-starring in a movie for the first
time but here's honestly the real deal
about Sean Levy directing Avengers
Secret Wars Deadpool 3 is essentially
going to be secret Wars in fact it's
literally going to be the story of
Secret Wars battle World from the comics
we've heard now from multiple insiders
that in Deadpool 3 the TVA will be
taking heroes from collapsing universes
from universes that have incursions
happening to them they'll be taking
these Heroes and putting them all on one
planet battle world that is right from
the comics and insiders have
acknowledged that this movie is going to
be very integral for the events that
lead directly into Secret Wars meaning
if Deadpool 3 doesn't happen Secret Wars
doesn't happen Kang Dynasty doesn't
happen The Insider can we get some toast
said this make no mistake Deadpool 3
will not just be a setup movie for
Avengers Secret Wars just like Infinity
war was its own contained story but was
integral for engram to even happen
Deadpool 3 will be the same to Secret
Wars so in a way Deadpool 3 is part one
to maybe a three part maybe a four part
if they decide to split Secret Wars into
two different parts but part one to a
three part currently secret War
storyline so he kind of already has his
own secret Wars movie well we know based
on the past for Avengers Infinity war
and Avengers end game that Marvel
Studios is interested in having the
person who directed the first part
direct the second they did this with the
Russo brothers and they were kind of
doing this before before they got rid of
the writers for Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars with Jeff loveness and Michael
Waldron the two of them have worked
together closely on Rick and Morty in
the past and they both wrote other MCU
films and shows and they were both
connected to Multiverse movies so they
wanted them to ride the big one since
they had that experience that's
essentially kind of what they did with
the Russo Brothers they directed the
Captain America movies Civil War
directly connected to Avengers Infinity
war and of course Infinity War connected
into end game and one could see why they
would want the same director to do both
projects so they feel the same so they
have the same continuity and that might
be the case here for Sean Levy rumors
have it that Marvel Studios want him to
direct the film and even recently he was
asked in an interview if he was going to
be directing that film he was asked by
E.T Canada about the rumor and this is
what he said there's a big old rumor out
there that when you're done Deadpool
that it might be Avengers I read that
rumor
and that's all I'm going to say and
that's all I'm gonna say so basically no
comment but again he is working with
Marvel Studios right now and he's
probably signed ndas it's the classic
interview conundrum you can't ever say
yep I'm doing it I'm directing the film
or a cast member going yep I'm in that
movie just like Paul Rudd denying that
he's Ant-Man Andrew Garfield saying he's
not the werewolf they can never really
say yes but the latest rumors tell us
that Marvel Studios is eyeing him to
direct Secret Wars and if Deadpool is
going to be such a massive success like
we all are hoping it's going to be and
like it sounds like it's going to be I
think it would be pretty great to have
Sean Levy direct the film everything
that I've seen from him has been really
really good great actually I've seen
some amazing things from him and I've
seen a lot of people out there say the
same thing however like I mentioned
Marvel Studios apparently has other
directors in mind and another one is Sam
Ramey now we talked about this a little
bit in a previous video but this kind of
makes sense twofold one he's Marvel
Legacy I mean he worked on the
Spider-Man films he directed Spider-Man
1-3 with Toby Maguire I mean the man is
a legend and like I've said before he
came into a pretty messy situation with
Doctor Strange and the Multiverse of
Madness I know some people have problems
with that movie but a script was already
written then they had to redo a lot of
it it was just pretty hectic and I
believe he did the best job with what he
was given but keep in mind he's not
going to be writing Secret Wars they're
just looking for directors and again the
second part to this is he is already
directed A Multiverse movie in the MCU
again going back to Marvel Studios kind
of wanting the same director who
directed something previous leading into
a big movie to also direct that big
movie so he directed Doctor Strange the
Multiverse of Madness which was a
multiversal film now he can direct
another multiversal film on a much
bigger scale Secret Wars and this time
do it properly have him come in at the
very beginning be involved with the
writing process that the writers do and
just basically get it right he's a very
admired director for all of the work
that he's done and I'm sure if he was
given a chance he'd crush it and it
sounds like Marvel Studios wants him as
well plus you have to realize that Kevin
feige has known and worked with him for
an incredibly long time baige worked
with him on the Spider-Man films when he
directed them and according to Insider
my time to shine hello she stated that
she has sources confirmed that Sam Remy
is Marvel's Top Choice to direct Secret
Wars now the reports about Sean Levy
being wanted by Marvel Studios came out
after this report so maybe some things
have changed but right now I'd say these
are our top two guys however there is
one more that was mentioned by Daniel
rbk who tweeted you know who I heard
they want to direct Secret Wars Alfonso
kuraron and this seems like it's coming
a little bit out of left field but he
has directed some big projects like
gravity and Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban and Children of Men
so a good name as far as directing is
concerned and he's been involved with a
lot of sci-fi fantasy types of films and
shows and perhaps that is why Marvel
Studios could be eyeing him to direct
Secret Wars so those who so far are the
top three choices reportedly for Marvel
Studios that we've heard about recently
let me know what you think about these
choices in the comments down below I
think if I had to go with anybody it
would probably be Sean Levy but it's
really close between him and Sam Raimi
but go ahead and let us know who you
would pick don't forget to like the
video and subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest MCU news you can of
course follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof